there was a bit in uh the TV show One
Division which is the one that just
leads into Doctor Strange
um and people were asking well how is he
not there surely that's exactly the kind
of situation he should be involved in
because he's he's a magic guy and Kevin
feige the guy who runs Marvel said uh
well it would look bad if we had a white
man coming in to show Wanda how to use
her powers
that's the mentality he's not allowed to
do that because he's the wrong sex and
he's the wrong ethnicity
that's the we're basically living with
like this this weird New Age like
segregationism in in movies there's
there's like a set of rules and laws
that these movies have to adhere to now
when it comes to their storytelling and
this is just one of the rules
can't have a guy especially a white guy
teaching a female character anything
valuable he has to be dumb and he has to
be useless and she has to be better than
him everything
fair enough but like that's it's like
trying to tell a story with with an arm
with one arm type behind your back you
know you're crippling the The Writer's
ability to tell a good story because
you're putting so many rules on them to
to try and appease all the ridiculous
demands of all the people on social
media now who get offended by everything
that you your ability to tell a
story
so it's also the same when it when it
comes to getting Awards didn't I hear
you talk about the fact that you're only
eligible for uh certain Awards if you
have the right kind of representation
both in front of the camera behind the
camera in terms of the studio and stuff
yeah the academy
um like for the Oscars um straight up
published their guidelines basically
saying your movie isn't even eligible to
be considered for an Oscar unless it's
got X percentage of of uh ethnic
minorities X percentage of women X
percentage of LGBT people uh all of that
stuff that is now the defining factors
and whether or not your movie is even
eligible for consideration for an award
of any kind and again I just have to ask
like why
like how does that improve the quality
of the film by just demanding that
certain people have to be involved in it
you know if God forbid you would just
hire people based on how good they were
in other jobs
you know and that's not gonna get any
better
yeah what so I'm going back to the
conversation especially around men
um
why do you think Hollywood hates men so
much at the moment
uh probably a guy named Harvey like that
was definitely part of it who who was
obviously you know he he got caught out
uh obviously did a lot of terrible
things and and rightly got uh you know
in prison for it uh but the result was
this seismic you know shock wave that
went through Hollywood and it just
became from that point uh we we can't
have
we can't have men in sort of positions
of power we can't have uh like
traditional strong masculine men uh in
in lead roles anymore and if if you ever
get a character like that they almost
always become the butt of a joke you
know it's always like ah look at this
guy thinking he's like Macho Man or
whatever and then he feels at something
uh it's always the same like Thor
yeah yeah like Thor big muscly guy just
becomes an absolute goofy clown because
isn't it funny to laugh at them uh you
know how many times have you seen a man
get kicked in the balls in a in a Disney
movie it's funny isn't it it's really
funny when that happens it's not so
funny when it happens to you though and
again you know you reverse the genders
there like if you showed a woman getting
kicked in the crotch like suddenly it's
not funny anymore you know like the the
it would have been a thermonuclear
explosion on social media if that was
ever shown on a in a in a mainstream
movie particularly if it was shown for
Laughs it's not gonna happen but it's
okay when it happens to men you know
it's just this weird double standard and
I think it partly
you know a big part of it is a result of
like Harvey and all that crap
um and a part of it is just a a shift in
the kind of culture in Hollywood that I
think was perhaps happening anyway
um
just trying to this constant drive to
like redefine masculinity which you know
often means like getting some skinny you
know 14 year old dude and putting them
in a dress and like saying this this is
masculinity you know like yeah sure it
is like whatever
um
but yeah that that kind of dual
almost pincer movement of like cultural
change within Hollywood and reaction to
to things that have been exposed within
their own ranks it's just been
um you know men masculine male heroes
are not a viable commodity in movies at
the moment you know uh but that's why
you get like something
I was just gonna say that's why when you
get the occasional movie that does dare
to show them they usually do really well
because people have been starved of this
stuff for years
what would be some examples of that like
Top Gun
probably yeah yeah it's pretty good
example
um yeah it was like it was a movie
that's combined all of those things
together like we were talking about you
know the the Aging mentor
who would normally be a subject of
mockery uh you know a different director
a different right area would have
portrayed Maverick as completely over
the hill and you know getting outclassed
by all these young
people who are faster and better than
him not this movie dared to say and it
was probably partly because Tom Cruise
and he's got an ego on him saying no
he's still good at what he does and you
know what he's
got way more experience than you he's
been there and done that and he can kick
your ass if he wants to he's still able
to do that uh and look what it did 1.5
billion dollars it was the biggest movie
of the Year by far and all these Marvel
properties that used to dominate and and
you know absolutely wipe the floor with
everything else they were trailing far
behind and it was I was very happy to
see that it pleased me
I so I watched I've flown a lot over the
last year so almost all of the movies
that I've seen have been on planes and I
really enjoyed Top Gun but I didn't
think it was ridic I would have given it
maybe a like a 7.5 probably an eight
probably an eight on the Tomato Meter I
think I would have given it so still
good but kind of shows that the bar
isn't exactly set superbly High
no you're yeah you're exactly right uh
we are just living in a world where
the movies that we're getting are so
terrible that anything that's just
borderline okay is suddenly held as a
masterpiece you know that that's it like
it's it's Lowered Expectations and so
this is what you get you know movies
like maybe it's a really smart it's
maybe it's a really smart strategy from
the movie studios to just get
everybody's expectations so low that
they can lowball us with something
that's brilliant I mean I don't think so
because well it's not like they can't
produce good movies they were doing it
for decades but then if you look back to
like your favorite movies of all time I
I'm willing to bet that none of them are
um newer than about 20 years old
you know they're probably all from the
the the 2000s the early 2000s
um back through the 90s the 80s the 70s
um I don't think there'll be anything
from the past 10 15 years
because the you know they've become lazy
they they've become lazy
um they have started relying on big
tentpole movies particularly remakes
particularly uh reboots of things
endless superhero movies you know that's
the been the money makers and it's just
inspired this culture of laziness in
them what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
face
[Music]